why do some architecture presentations
and like this
[Music]
and some and like this
[Applause]
today i'm going to be talking about four
key components
to a compelling architecture
presentation
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dami and i'm
a licensed architect in vancouver bc
so this is a new section of the channel
called the presentation corner
where i'm going to give you some tools
and strategies to create
a compelling architecture presentation
i'm sure you've seen instances where
good projects get bad reviews because of
poor presentations
and bad projects come alive because
of a really good presentation a lot of
times
if it is a really bad project it's
pretty hard to hide
but there are so many ways to structure
a presentation
to focus on your strengths and not the
weak
areas that you didn't spend too much
time on i also kind of believe that
architects need to become
better communicators inside school but
also outside of school
architecture is not just about the
construction of buildings but it's
inspiring the world with our ideas
and i think that when we can share ideas
and communicate them better to the wider
public
we can get better buildings we can have
better communities
and we can have a better profession so
today i'm going to be covering
four key aspects of a presentation that
i always try to think about before i
even start putting together my slides
so i've split up the video into four
sections
first one concept wrapping how to wrap
the presentation
around your concept or the problem that
you're trying to solve
and number two uh continuous engagement
and i'll give you some tools you can use
to keep your audience
constantly engaged and not bored
throughout the presentation
and then number three will be
comprehensiveness um
how to make sure that your audience is
not just engaged
but they're understanding every point
you're talking about
and then number four satisfaction this
is the end result uh the combination
of all of these points and it's kind of
the gut feeling
of our new project but i think
ultimately it's the difference between
a really memorable presentation and uh
average presentation
so i'll give you an example with one of
my projects uh this project is called
symbiosis
and i won the td bank award
from the toronto society of architects
and
um what's interesting about this project
is that
i never really showed a rendering of
what the building looks like
from the outside um and
it's a project that won like pretty much
because of its concept
so the product brief was to create an
office tower of the future
uh but not too far in the future it was
the office of 2020
which is now so before even starting i'm
explaining the project with a series of
very simple
diagrams that explain the concept behind
the building
so basically i wanted to create um a
unique environment
throughout the building but just
recognize that you know
creating a unique condition for every
floor is going to be really really
really freaking expensive
and if we ended up doing that
the cost of renting a floor
would be extremely expensive and so it
would
only be rented out to super high income
companies and so what i did is instead
of changing the size
or the shape of each floor plate i
changed the
size of the atrium so yeah that's what
this diagram is showing so continuously
changing size of the atrium throughout
the building
and then the changing size of the atrium
alters the usage
of the regular floor plates and
therefore a variety of firms and
organizations can choose
a floor that is best suited to their
functional
and economic needs and then so that's a
site diagram
showing how the building is connected to
the rest of the city
and this is a another site diagram
showing how the building is connected to
an underground
path network this building was based in
toronto by the way
um and in toronto because it's uh it
gets down to like
negative 30 degrees there is a very
extensive underground network and so
um the basement floor of this building
is connected to
that the pack it's called the path and
so people can come up
to the community space in this building
from the path network and so here i'm
showing the elevations
sections and the floor plans but i'm
showing it in a way that
reinforces the concept so based on this
section
drawing that we have here you can see
that
by changing the size of the atrium you
can alter
the usage of the floor plate so this one
can be split into
two small firms this can be used by
one large organization this one also
split into two and then on this side i
actually have the floor plan
where you can see how the space is being
used
and then on the next page
i will have the renderings
for each floor plan and then we have the
section of the ground floor which is
um it's a this is all commercial retail
so it's open to the public and then the
basement floor
is the floor that's connected to the
path network
and then all of this becomes a indoor
garden so that people can use it
use the space during the winter as well
and so right below the section
i will have a diagram so this is
a public private diagram showing
the red section as the private and
all of the blue section as the public
and so this is directly connected to my
concept of symbiosis which means
symbiosis means a mutually beneficial
relationship
um and then on next page i'll have
a rendering showing this
fountain detail
and then on the next page i'll have
another section another orthographic
drawing
um but i will have another diagram
showing how the building is connected to
the network
on the ground on the basement level and
how
the um public and
private are intermingled together and
then on the next page i'll have
a rendering of the uh garden space
and then another one is by interjection
so you
interject your concept um every
like two or three slides okay so this is
a slightly different example
um it's some of the slides from my
thesis project
so this project was a little bit unique
because i had five different buildings
within
one project and each building was
addressing
like a unique concept and
instead of presenting the building
through
drawings i actually presented it through
um
an experiential section so
um this is like one of the buildings in
the project
and so i would walk people through the
space
and then i would change the background
color into white
and here i'm actually describing going
back
to the concept going out of the building
going back to the concept
and giving a brief description of what
concept this building is resolving
and of course i'm using similar graphics
to what we were seeing in the building
right and then
another example with another building is
once again
i walk people through the building
through an experiential section
and then i briefly come back to
the concept that this building is trying
to resolve
and then once again i jump back into the
concept so yeah this is another example
of how you can wrap the concept
around your project so a lot of students
in their early years
think that they have to present the
building
so they will spend a lot of time talking
about the plans
here's the section here's the elevation
because those are
the requirements typically in a brief
it'll say okay you have to present the
orthographic drawings
through plan section elevation
renderings
but you have a pretty limited amount of
time in your presentation right
so you just want to show the parts of
your building
that's essential to your concept
and there's always a q a afterwards
and so if you want you can clarify those
details later
so the key difference is using your
drawings not to show your
building but using it to show your
concept
we all have a very short attention span
everyone feels like they have
more important things to do and
you know even if it's your jury who has
to be there
uh they're just not gonna react
favorably to a project if they're born
and also you're not really respecting
their time and presence
if you're boring them right so
in that time span of 5 to 20 minutes
you need to keep your audience engaged
and
keep them focused for the entirety of
the presentation and
uh while you're presenting some very
complex concepts
also when you're presenting you kind of
have to think about yourself
as like this person that's putting on a
show
that's gonna be reflected in your
posture the way that you're talking
the way you're gesturing your hands
and you just really want to have control
over the room so i've even seen people
go and direct exactly where they want
people to sit
if you feel like it's gonna benefit you
to have people
uh sit on the floor then you make sure
you go
and arrange the room uh so that everyone
sits on the floor as soon as they come
in
one of the ways i like to create
engagement is through visual continuity
so this is a really simple example it's
i actually showed this in my other video
about the border crossing in the dmz
but see how the diagrams
all connect visually i'm using some of
the same elements so that it's very
easy for them to understand what i'm
talking about
and then another example so in this one
i had a lot of
complex cultural concepts that i had to
go over before i even started talking
about my building
so here i'm using this
circle as a tool and
i'm showing how these different
elements are connected so
um i had four concepts i wanted to
address
anti-library categorization speed
reading
and speed and distraction and i had to
explain
different concepts within that category
and so by just scrolling through these
images
in these four points um the audience is
able to understand that okay
this derive is in the category of speed
and distraction and the labyrinth
and they can see how that connects
to the other category speed and reading
so if you have a bunch of different
concepts that you're addressing
it's a really good way for you to create
context
it helps them situate what you're
talking about in the wider context
of the project and so this is how i even
talk about my site
and also i use very little text in my
presentations as you can see
uh because everyone understands visuals
more clearly
and i will be reinforcing
the visuals with what i'm saying
um and then there's visual continuity
with
images as well right
just using the same row of photos
showing that you're progressing in space
and then another strategy i like to use
is tension and release
so same example as before
series of very dark black and white
photos
and then you have release with a bright
rendering another
is another example would be this is
another
experiential section from my thesis
project
and then so i'm walking them through
the building through a series of
sections and renders and then i'll
release with a rendering
so the third component to a compelling
presentation
is comprehensiveness meaning the
audience has a really good understanding
of all the concepts that you talked
about uh at the end of the presentation
so i think one of the most important
things is to provide context
throughout your presentation so
architecture presentations
are typically um very complex
and sometimes very long and you probably
have a pretty good idea of what you're
talking about because you've been
working on the project for a long time
but you know sometimes
even the smartest people can't follow
what you're talking about
sometimes you'll be talking about a
space and one of the jury members will
go like
uh is it is that over here you're like
uh no it's actually over here to me
that's
like one of the worst things that could
happen in a presentation
because at that point you've kind of
lost your credibility
and your ability to uh walk people
through the space
and you know you realize that they
didn't really have an idea what you were
talking about
so um one of the ways to avoid that
is to make it as easy as possible for
them
to follow along and keep giving them
visual cues of where they are in the
presentation
okay so i'll give you another example
here this is another project it was
a renovation of a brutalist building
um and so we were doing some like
exterior and
interior retrofits and so you can see
here
that i am basically like half of the
page
is taken up with the plan and the other
half
is with renderings and i
have these view cones as i walk them
through the presentation
showing exactly where they are in the
building and as you go through the
presentation
you don't just have to show renderings
right you can also show
details and axos that are in that
particular space
um and then some renderings and then
you'll have your
like moment of release with a big
section
so i'll go through the space and then
show them
oh and in this space i have details
that look like this so that's a that's
one of the examples
and then another example i showed you
this before
and so this is a project where i didn't
really
walk them through um the building
through my drawings i used
an experiential section to walk them
through the building
and i had printouts of the orthographic
drawings so
that they can kind of refer back to it
as i'm talking
this project was composed of like four
little buildings
and so what you can see is in the corner
over there
i had a little um key plan
showing where we are in the building and
i kept the key plans there
even as we were going through the
concepts because i
i really wanna treat the audience
as if they're like really stupid i want
to make it super super super obvious for
them
uh where we are in the building and what
i'm talking about and then another
example is like if you just want to show
an exterior of your building and um show
them
how your building uh reacts to the sun
throughout the day you can do that as
well by
like what i did is i
just highlighted the areas of the
building
that we're focusing on and then did a
close-up
of that area
so a satisfying presentation comes full
circle
so what you present at the beginning of
the presentation
is reinforced over and over again
throughout the project
and the concept builds and
develops throughout the presentation and
in the end it's fully reinforced it
leaves the audience with a sense of awe
or learning something new so
in order for a project to be satisfying
the audience
first they need to be engaged throughout
the journey
and they have to fully understand all
the concepts a satisfying ending has
like
a wow moment so you can end with like
a money shot
[Music]
a good presentation feels good and
that's the thing that's going to make
your presentation memorable
so those are some of the key elements
that i like to think about before
i even start putting together a
presentation
i hope you guys found this helpful we
have another
video where i talk about how you can
present
case studies in a way that can help you
defend your ideas
i will be making more videos like this
on
presentation techniques so if you
haven't subscribed already sorry
if you like this video please give me a
thumbs up
and um yeah i'll see you guys in the
next video
[Music]
you